kamel je suis ravis de t'accueillir dans
notre équipe pour nous aider à gagner la
région et pour nous aider surtout à
protéger les bourguignons et les franc
comtois ce devait être la prise du lion
un jeune maghrébin issu des quartiers
musulmans pratiquants la caution
politiquement correct rêver du
rassemblement national en fait une vaste
imposture
kamel agac gujarat la tête de liste
belfortaine avoue n'avoir jamais roulé
pour l'extrême droite
c'est tellement des acteurs que je me
suis dit bien moi aussi je vais jouer à
peu ce rôle d'acteur là et honnêtement
c'était pas compliqué j'étais pas
compliqué je vais te parler de violence
et d'insécurité
quand le premier ministre castex a
repoussé d'une semaine je me dis oh là
là je vais devoir tenir une semaine de
plus j'ai été dégoûté mais en tout cas
j'attends d'elle et 26 27 juin avec
impatience pour être élu et je
m'imaginais déjà dans ma tête dans
l'hémicycle où c'est que j'allais
m'asseoir affronter le regard etc etc
parce que j'allais faire tomber le
masque le plus rapidement possible une
fois ils luttent pour le mouvement la
trahison est cuisante encarté depuis
quelques mois à peine imposée par la
hiérarchie au détriment de militants
historiques la tête de liste n'avait
vraiment pas la tête de l'emploi
me l'a présenté deux heures avant sa
présentation officielle en conférence de
presse vendredi dernier
je n'ai pas vraiment cru en la sincérité
son discours un sentiment une différence
de sensibilité quant à l'appréciation du
candidat par rapport par rapport à
monsieur odoul la volonté de
dédiaboliser le parti at elle aveugle et
les cadres du mouvement
le patron régional nie farouchement
avoir voulu faire le buzz le problème
c'est pas c'est pas le profil du
candidat le problème c'est véritablement
le déchaînement de haine sur les réseaux
sociaux
la pression dans son quartier la
violence je suis bien et les menaces sur
l'aspiré de sa famille qui l'ont fait
évidemment renoncer et surtout qui ont
fait qu'ils sont qui sont même allés
jusqu'à le faire renier son engagement
une chose est sûre kamel boudjellal n'a
jamais milité que pour l'insertion et en
dehors des partis silit avoir abandonné
son cheval de troie face à la n
l'amateur des chats qui a réussi à
placer ses pions pour appeler
aujourd'hui à voter contre marine le pen
il faut mobiliser
faut aller voter il faut vous réunir et
ça fonctionne j'ai toujours dis moi
qu'une voix ça faisait plus de bruit
qu'une voiture brûlée je l' ai toujours
dit et le candidat infiltré de promettre
qu il restituera son expérience dans un
livre